[Music]
what
[Music]
oh we've done it folks we've got one of
the biggest lads in the game on the
podcast today and on top of all that the
kid can play it's hard to believe that
he's only 24 years old his consistent
performances and the yellow and black
colors for the hurricanes make him one
of the all-time greats and his form in
the black jersey this season has seen
him become one of the best players in
the world he also possesses arguably the
longest kick in the game and comes up
clutch almost every time and yes like i
mentioned at the start he is one of the
great lads so i'm stoked to have him on
what a lad it is the man himself jordy
barrett welcome donny
thanks jabber uh it's great to be on
here some kind words um
yeah i had to i couldn't turn this one
down after seeing toby uh requesting to
have me on so it's great to be here
but it is it has been pretty cool to be
fair seeing how much influence someone
like you can have on such a young kid i
mean he just came to hurricanes training
one day you walk up to him say hello
give him a high five and now he's been
obsessed with you for those last for
that last year and a half and
rides every game of yours like it's like
it's his and it's been pretty cool to
see the influence that someone like you
can have on just a just a normal kid
yeah that's nice um
you love hearing those stories and you
don't you only cast your own mind back
and
even when i was turning out to watch
footy players or whatnot you remember
the ones that gave you a bit of time
even if it was 10 seconds so that's cool
mate you're a bloody good inspiration to
have for him because other than that red
card that you got where he was in tears
everything else has been smooth sailing
good stuff
but let's start with the tour mate
obviously you'll be pretty stoked with
how your performance had been going uh
you would have been going into that tour
hoping to sort of get a good crack at
that 15 jersey but by the end of it
you'd um firmly cemented it yeah it was
an interesting and a long tour but
plenty of learnings
um
like
the situation we put in with covered
everyone's going through it so it was
never going to be an excuse for us um we
knew we knew that as soon as he got on
the plane and went straight to perth um
we had a good rugby championship
a few good wins
uh one we lost against south africa
which was frustrating um after we'd
already signed up the torah um
and then going into
europe and the usa for the second league
um it was pretty challenging i think two
and a half two months and
and it's not easy going up there where
uh
northern northern strong northern teams
are waiting for you um yeah and you're
at the end of your season so there was
always going to be a challenge pretty
frustrating again to
finish the way we did against ireland
and france but like it's
a little rock under the beach alba um
test footy comes in cycles and hopefully
next time we go up there um in a couple
years we can um sort something out and
your form personally obviously it
started probably not ideally with that
arguable red card
that was your sort of first opportunity
in that jersey and then did you feel
like maybe that was your opportunity
gone after that game did you feel like
yeah with the competition around did you
feel like maybe that was your one shot
to be honest yeah yeah um
yeah i wasn't sitting too comfortable
there for a couple days um
like i've been trying hard to get an
opportunity for a couple years to start
in the 15 jersey and try and solidify a
spot there and just get some minutes um
to be honest
and
like the adrenaline was pumping we just
scored a good try against australia
they do a box kick or get off balance
marika ends up collecting my
um
size 12 which wasn't flash um didn't
look great and i haven't very quickly um
and then got recorded
i was in shock to be honest when it went
off needed a part of my intention to
kick him in the face and
um let's just say the judiciary
um
went on for a while
had fozzie and brad moore that brad
moore's um an ex-lawyer so
that helps i think it was about two and
a half hours um after training one day
on zoom
speaking to
two south african people on a panel and
one argentinian guy
and
i was i'd never been through that
judiciary process before and
it was unbelievable like
we had someone doing
um understanding the physics of the
timing of when i'm in the air and when i
was coming down and certain angles and
yeah i was a little bit taken back by it
to be honest but that's crazy common
sense prevailed and i was allowed to
play that next week and
yeah i guess got the opportunity to play
15 again for the rest of the tour so it
was nice yeah what's your role in that
judiciary process do you have to speak
how long are you speaking for pleading
your
case basically
my job was just to say
what i thought and what i felt within
the moment in the game i had the other
people with me that done all the
homework and
so i didn't want to overspeak and i
guess jeeperize my position um if i'd
inflicted any of their findings
so
i just explained how i was feeling
going up to catch the ball basically
said
i'd overrun the over around the timing i
had to jump up and lean back to catch
the ball on my chest and just tilt my
body backwards and it was as simple as
that and
just sat there and watched everything
else unfold for the next two and a half
hours
loving life it was quite daunting
because
we're in the zone
so they'll have the panel and one sort
of meeting room and then us
is in all blacks and another meeting
room so it would come together as a full
judiciary
panel
and then
they'd go away and discuss findings for
20 minutes half an hour we'd go into a
different room as such on zoom and we
just have to sit there and it was
antagonizing like you're just waiting to
let's reach a verdict and then you'd
come back into the room again and
explain what
has just happened it's like a murder
scene oh
honestly i felt like i'd killed someone
that day
but like you did like you said that you
did get your um 15 jersey the following
week and that was against south africa
and um obviously they loved the high
ball so you would have been preparing
yourself for
plenty of those and you came up trumps
in that game so talk talk to me about
that one
yeah
we knew it was coming at those two tests
against south africa um put the helmet
on that week
whoever was on the turtle i can't
remember it might have been sibu that
week um
he's not a happy camper
like for people last name turtles the
big pad that you have on your back
so
the nines are just kicking their hemmies
off and all the outsiders just
bombarding civil on the turtle and it
got to a point where he headed enough he
chucked the turtle on the ground and
then i think quintuplet had to jump on
we just spent training
all our little five-minute window box
just catching eyeballs and um
look we weren't surprised in the weekend
um but just it came straight towards us
stuff to clear
yeah what what is your mindset going up
for those high balls
i guess for me
when i'm catching them well you just got
to take everything else out of the
equation it's as simple as
you go and going up there to catch the
ball you start thinking about
your own escort runners or their chasers
or if you're going to meet someone in
the air
then you start getting into trouble so
you just got to simplify it
just get your own timing judge the ball
where it is and just go up and get it i
find you have to go up and meet at the
top
and the guy on the ground beside you
generally the other outside back um
he makes a massive
massive difference if he's there to tell
you to stay up or stay down or catch it
above your head that that's everything
so um
we we found a founder we planned um it
didn't work too well in the first game
but um we caught enough
eyeballs as such to win that game mate i
wish i wish you told me this about five
years ago
that's great advice for guys under the
high ball
it's wizardry stuff i love that
but you're also
in those games you also thing that stood
out was how clutch you were especially
oh both games to be fair you kicked the
winning goal in that first one and
you should have done the same in the
second one um
until until they ended up doing it
themselves but what was your mindset
lining up those kicks what's it like
trying to kick a winning goal for the
all blacks is it the same as a normal
kick or
not quite
i've been in two opportunities with the
hurricanes before and they're probably
the only times in my career i've had a
chance to win
games um got one of them the first one
missed the second one against the
brumbies um which
was nagging at me for
two or three or four months um it just
grated me because the other ones you
want to kick but it's just the nature of
it you can't get them all but
i guess that learning
phase from that helped me um
i think the the time
between the end of our super season and
the rugby championship i actually went
away and changed my kicking technique a
little bit
um it wasn't a knee-jerk reaction to one
kick i just felt like i had a little bit
too much clutter at the back of my run
up yeah um there was the knee lift with
my left leg at the back of my runner um
and i was thought look if i'm going to
kick a hundred balls that knee lift
isn't going to be exactly the same all
100 times so
if it's a little well off ten times
within these ten different kicks and
timing so
um basically just went away tried to
simplify my run up a little bit and
i still keep that flow um still try kick
the skin off and kick it as straight as
possible so um
i wasn't too nervous um to be honest
with that kick in townsville um i had
like like i said before i'd gone away
and worked on my kicking game quite a
lot
so i was feeling pretty good about
standing over that ball um
yeah just lucky it
went through held my breath a little bit
as it started hitting towards the left
upright but
um i feel like i'm in a good spot with
it at the moment
right it's definitely working whatever
you're doing but it's interesting
hearing you talk about that brumby's
miss kick and how it sort of sat with
you for so long because one thing i sort
of remember about you is just your
ability to
um sort of forget about mistakes and
just continue playing without it ever
affecting you you might have a moment
where you do a loose offload and you're
in the same position this maybe five
minutes later in that time you'll you'll
try it again but this time you'll nail
it
it's one of the real strengths of your
game so it's interesting hearing how
that brumby's kick really really sat
with you yeah for sure um it's one thing
within my game
um you just try and take each moment and
look if i see something and back my
instinct will then
i'm just going to back that interesting
the times that things don't work because
then
is when i think about that split second
and i pause i'm instinct that generally
um you'll make a mistake but what
coaches and
players always tell you nine times out
of ten the instinct will tell you the
right thing so
that's one thing i try to have in my
game but i guess i don't have that
luxury at home after missing that kick
chatter we're out of the competition and
a chance to kick a goal for another
three months so that's probably why i
was thinking about it
yeah that's true because it was 80
minutes hey time was up
yeah time was up that's right and we've
kept the brick from halfway about eight
minutes earlier um
that's still as
as good as you
want to be as a kicker um like you can't
get them all so i learned that that day
that's and how were the boys around that
did anyone give you a spit a stick or
were they all good about it they
obviously knew that you'd save them that
many times beforehand you said it you'd
only done it once before but mate i feel
like you're kicking clutch kicks every
week for the for the canes might not be
right on full time but
big moments in big games
yeah i've kicked a few down the
stretching games do you ever but not
ones to
um
to win games and
but
that i was always a little bit
disgruntled because i was thinking [ __ ]
i'm a goal kicker i think three or four
years into my career now and i've never
had the chance to win a game and i
wanted to do that um
it's nice to win them but it's not so
nice when you're on the other side of it
i remember a few boys um
i guess walking on eggshells around
talking about kicking around me for a
few weeks but
um like i'm i'm pretty good about her
pretty tongue-in-cheek i think lastly
much longer up there i think yeah a
couple days and so mad monday maybe some
boys that might have been giving me a
bit of chat
i'm sure you gave it back no doubt but i
guess with a tour that long um you had
guys had a lot plenty of down time and
uh talking to
dmacc and
will jordan the last few days
sounds like you a absolute gun on the
golf course scratch golfer can't believe
that
um my handicap index is so jimmy but i
didn't play like it for most of tiller
and that's quite frustrating
um
i was pacing the hallway before my last
round in france
with a wedge in hand thing and she
actually a good golfer or not
after
going
above my handicap for most the tour um
and the boys are probably asking similar
questions like is this guy actually good
at golf
um i like i got a couple of nice rounds
in on tour which is good i play
a lot in the summer
actually a lot um during the season as
well um
yeah coaches i think already know that
but um
yeah
play quite a bit sneak off after
training and try to get 18 in so when
did you start playing golf what age
started playing golf for eight years old
oh yeah i used to get dropped off um
at the
pongarhou
golf
club
which is at the top of the road
where we live on the farm and granddad
lived on that golf course there's a
sheep course
so there's sheep on the golf course
basically mowing the fields
and
i just get off get off the bus and
walk down the hill with granddad head
we didn't actually go on to the course
too often we'd only go on there on club
day on sunday but we'll just walk down
the hill he'd put a car tire out and out
on the middle of the fairway and i just
stand there and chip falls into a car
tire for
for an hour or hour and a half and
then wait till mom and dad have finished
milking the cows and i'd come pick me up
and we'd go home
mate that's that's babysitting like that
that's a great idea
[Laughter]
you've obviously lived a very eventful
life for a 24 year old
you've done so much in in your short
time so let's let's go back to the start
what was it like 24 years ago yeah um 24
years ago i was two weeks late um
and
i meant to get in juice and my brothers
always give me
a better stack because
it probably took me about 23 years to
get my time management sorted
um
i always thought i was pretty am a
teammate so i thought it was pretty
blase rolling into meetings a couple
minutes beforehand um without a worry on
my face and that's in this
arms trying to call me thinking where
are you
little walk in be sweet as happy as
larry [ __ ] yeah um
yeah 24 years ago yeah born and raised
on the coast with a big family like you
said and what was it like what was it
like being raised on the farm with
all your your massive family
yeah it was awesome mate um
we
us kids were so lucky um
mum and dad worked so hard and
set us up gave us all the opportunities
in the world
they it wasn't till
i guess at high school or even leaving
high school at appreciation for
what they did i don't know how you
juggle having eight kids um and such
hard workers like you'll struggle to get
dead off the farm
mum was on the farm milking um
rearing calves um
and then trying to cook and
do all the things and just be a mother
um for eight kids so
appreciation that us boys and girls have
for them um
yeah they are awesome um
obviously had a lot of help from our
grandparents and neighbors and family
friends as well because you'd imagine on
a saturday morning
um you got four or five direct different
directions to go so yeah um
yeah it was awesome and growing up with
four older brothers um it probably
couldn't have been any better for me we
we looked after ourselves as
mum and dad are working and um it was
awesome yeah and we've obviously heard
from bodhi on a couple of your backyard
stories what you guys used to get up to
but it must be crazy to think back and
realize that you were actually playing
backyard footy with a couple of all
blacks and it probably would have been
three if kane didn't get the concussions
i mean he was a beast as well so crazy
to think the quality of your backyard 40
games yeah it was awesome actually our
cricket game is probably better um we're
weird where the grass are on our back
lawn and um we'd often stay out there
and
i was the curator of our home ground
called the bcg barrett cricket ground so
um
all 40 kilos of me or whatever i was
back back then i'd be leaning on a
roller that i got from dad's implement
shed
um just walking back and forward on this
patch
rolling it and
i guess trying to get this deck as flat
as possible um
to try and have some good qriket games
and um
looking back now it's probably not the
smartest thing to do because
i ended up just bowling to my brothers
on a road all afternoon so um
we'd come in not at six or seven o'clock
when it was done at dinner time um would
come in when the sun went down
so that was some awesome games in the
backyard crowley boys as well across the
road so you probably did you prefer
cricket at this age um
up until
19 years old um i was just completely 50
50 crooked in the summer rugby in the
winter
that's pretty cliche but like most
kiwi boys um and girls
um
but like it was until i guess someone
else made a decision for me that i went
the rugby path
and was that the new zealand under 20s
because i remember i remember you coming
into training one day
with the naki and you mate you were you
were pretty gifted like i remember
thinking firstly that you've come to the
wrong unit session you you're supposed
to be with the forwards and then your
your skill set was just next level uh
and then i remember asking i think it
must been clarky afterwards if you were
signed or what the deal with you was and
he said that no i think he's he's off to
cricket where he's not going to play
rugby and i was i remember just being
absolutely shocked so was that was that
legit you were genuinely thinking you
were you're off to cricket
yeah i think that might have been my
first
well my summer straight out of school
then um
popping in and seeing you dominating for
the nike it was great watch together
um
glory days
well i think
yeah that stage um i was trying to push
really hard for the new zealand
under-19s i think they had a tour to
bangladesh or uae um then and that was
in february
um
and well the following following summer
so i went to
the tournament cd under 19s
and i thought i was a good sniff of
making that
probably underperformed at the
tournament and didn't get picked got
picked as a non-traveling reserve
um
and fair enough i probably wouldn't have
picked um
back to me either after watching ebola
that tournament got slapped everywhere
on roads down at lincoln lincoln oval
um
but and then
just went down to lincoln i guess a
month later
um after i didn't get picked for that
world cup
and went straight into lincoln rugby
uh crusaders nights the year after then
under 20 so having pretty quick
crazy yeah so if you made that um new
zealand under 19 do you reckon you would
have been playing qriket now um
probably i genuinely think i would be um
because at that stage i didn't make i
didn't make new zealand schools or new
zealand barbarians for rugby so
that would have been my first
representative team
um with the under 19s as a cricketer so
um
who knows
probably lucky i didn't get picked they
might have found out a couple years
later that that was a bust so
um you know hopefully this leaked has
done me a favor
and you talked about your uh move down
to lincoln uni give us a rundown on that
that were that must have been where you
learnt to drink your piss so quickly
yeah what do you want to know
what was your living arrangement level
start there okay um went down there
i was actually on a rugby scholarship
um
so i had to be there and
um
i guess train a little bit of footy and
actually maintain some grade so
it probably kept me in line a little bit
i was on the halls for the first year
um
i just played
um colt's footy yeah um we had a great
name celestia ariasi and brick cameron
oh a couple
of so we weren't even playing scenic
club footy we're just playing colts
mucking around to be honest um
and
yeah like you said just enjoying being a
uni student um
rolling out a beard at 11 o'clock um
going to go into lectures
at about one o'clock for an hour um
and standing around in the cafe deciding
whether we should go to the next lecture
or fighting with it just to
go and kick some seeds all afternoon and
um
often there was the latter so
i wasn't very much of a student to be
honest i was pretty like i was good at
school um
but
i guess when i had
i could make my own decisions down there
um
yeah i drifted away but how many times
were you on the source a week down there
um
generally student student night was
wednesday night um
so wednesday night for sure
and then
depending on
if anything was happening on a thursday
often my rubber arm would get twisted on
a
thursday and then friday friday just a
day for the dust to settle and then um
saturday and then
then you're gonna have a few beers after
footy on saturday anya so the t-snap
saturday night
in the second year i went into it
uh while i was still down there we lived
in christchurch we're in a seven-man
flat
we found a
flat in centennial avenue um
a couple of footy boys couple guys from
down south and
yeah that was probably one one of the
great years
my life to be up to be to be honest um
yeah for a number of reasons is that the
year you're playing for canterbury
and the npc yeah that was my canary yeah
mate and what a year you had for them i
think you ended up winning play of the
year you're what 19 years old absolutely
killing it
yeah it was a massive year it was my
first year of
um
club footy
um so played senior club footy for the
first year that year
and to be honest i was still pretty
naive at that stage love footy
and generally didn't think i was too
too crash shot at it um
i obviously had a skill set because i
trained hard and was
always on the lawn as a youngster but um
obviously a few guys saw a little bit of
me but that year went pretty quick got
chosen by rosa to play for canterbury um
and we won the competition
playing with scott when my brother which
is awesome run won the rentfully shield
so um that was just an unbelievable yeah
and your form was that good that you
ended up being called into the all
blacks as an apprentice was that
straight after the this season yeah it
was i think was the
it was the day after so we'd won the
competition had a massive
night um obviously after winning the
final
got home and there's a few of us boys
just lounging around um
in a flat and
got a call from a random number i don't
normally pick up phone calls from random
numbers but smart
it was girl with anarchy
um
hey mate girl with nokia here um
look we've selected you to come on the
northern tour
um as an apprentice and i was like
hang on so i looked down my phone again
looked around inside make sure none of
the boys is pranking me yeah um as you
know all too well
um but then yeah he basically told me um
he was going on that northern tour as an
apprentice couldn't play but
that was an unbelievable experience i
think
i got told that i wasn't going to be
selected
regardless of injuries so
from monday to friday every single day i
was in the gym
um even in a day off and i think i went
in there and i was
maybe 91 kilos
yeah or 92 kilos uh five week tour um
and i come out of there at about 98.99
kilos
um
so just eating and that girl just had me
on the stupid gym program all the boys
are in there doing their power session
on a thursday smiling laughing around
and i'm in to my 8 to 12 reps in the
corner just completely under it like
i've never seen a gym before in my life
and
all of a sudden i'm just throwing in so
here use this five weeks to put some
sighs on
that's crazy and what's it like being in
the all black environment knowing that
you can't play
um and as an apprentice did you feel
like you were a part of the team or was
it quite an awkward sort of feeling that
was awesome um
it's a bit of a luxury having two
brothers in there which made that step a
little bit easier yeah
so now it was a great phase for me
learns a lot um
most of those guys in there that staged
um i had pictures of them on my bedroom
wall so
it was an unbelievable experience down
at the uni halls
yeah the uni hills the pictures are
probably on the wall to cover the holes
in the wall
and then you obviously move to the
hurricane so talk to me about this one
my memory of it was bodhi told me that
um he asked me if i was leaving or not
and he said if you if i leave that you
will sign with the hurricane so although
i did a few good things at the canes i
feel like the best thing i ever did for
that hurricanes franchise
was leave so that you could go there is
there any truth into that
i didn't know that actually java i was
actually disappointed when i found out
that you were leaving
they promised me that you're going to
offer a mental mentoring role um
as a young buddy 15 and then
turned up there and had to take his life
well that worked out pretty well for you
but what was what was the real um story
obviously razer would have been keen as
to get you at the crusaders
yeah it was tough because i was on a
high at that stage um
after playing with scott for a year and
that was such good fun
but
there's a lot of me like i grew up as a
hurricane supporter and that age year
like i was 19 so i was still a fan in a
way and all i ever wanted to do was play
for the hurricane so
there's a big emotional attachment to
the hurricanes um obviously bodhi was
there dad played there and just the fact
that it's a little bit closer to home
obviously enjoyed christchurch love
lincoln
but it just meant i was able to get home
during long weekends by weekends and
just get back to the farm and i guess
connect with my mates up at home as well
so
um who knows how things would have
panned out if i'd stay down there but um
yeah i've got no regrets i love my time
at hurricanes and i'm happy to be here
well you've been massive for that that
team over the last few years it's
i'm very glad you made that decision but
what was it like going into the
environment what did you you'd obviously
come from the all blacks environment
already so did you feel quite
comfortable in the in the super rugby
setup
um
well it certainly helped um being in
that all blacks environment but
then again i had this tag on me um i was
an all blacks apprentice i've only
played
12 games of mitre 10
um
cup um
the younger brother of two current all
blacks so there's a tag there and a bit
to answer for so um i was i was pretty
driven by that um
and obviously wanted to succeed myself
so um yeah i'd i had some big a couple
of early big years with the canes and
just tried to train train hard and keep
my head down and
um yeah that's all i tried to do for
those first two years just and earn a
better respect through um playing well
so that's all i wanted to do when i went
up to wellington obviously enjoyed it a
good group of mates here at the moment
you mentioned the success that your
brothers had did you feel like that
pressure was with you all the way
through even as a junior did you feel
like you had a reputation to live up to
in the rugby scene sometimes it did um
particularly last few years at high
school um when i wanted to be a
professional footy player um i think
bodhi just debuted the all blacks so um
it's showing us that
that can happen um
you know like i said earlier i wasn't
too crash shot at secondary school
like i played well enough but wasn't
gifted with um size or speed or anything
extra and
you said to grind it out for a few years
there so
yeah they hung over me for for a little
bit but like i said before it just gave
me plenty of motivation and
um it was certainly never a burden i was
i felt like i was gifted and lucky
enough to
have those boys to talk to about footy
and um i guess like us like i said
before they paved the way and showed us
how it's done so
i was grateful for them and obviously
proud watching them growing up as a kid
what about the constant comparisons
between you and bodhi or things like
that from especially from fans says
do you get do you cop that all the time
yeah it used to happen quite a lot um i
guess the easiest sledge and i don't
know how many team how many teams or
fans or players have said to me
um you're not the better brother or yeah
well there's beard and i'm thinking
i've actually got three other brothers
um
kane probably is better than me at the
moment too
so scott um so
so it's pretty funny and blake's a
better cricketer as well yeah
um but look they it was amazing it was
an easy target um
but like i don't see it as a burden um
yes he is in a in a good position
mate and look at you now mate you're
dominating the world stage but there was
a few moments in there in your
hurricane's career which were a little
bit dicey one was a one that we've had
about a thousand questions about um
before the end but we'll mention it now
was the mecca's incident you're down in
dunedin you end up at someone's house
with mecca's
what has happened here
yeah it's a bit of a um
yeah not my best work to be honest
chatter um
like i think we had
i'm not sure if we wanna lost the game
anyway it's irrelevant um the team had a
big night at
vault 21
um
things yeah just a big night
post game um few beers and
to be honest all i was after was greys
um so
i was with a mate and
i think we ubered to um mcdonald's and
got a feed
and then just went for a walk and just
enjoyed being out in dunedin um
just walked and talked on the street um
he thought in knowing
a person that was in the flat um
so i thought it'd be a good idea to walk
in there about three in the morning
i'd never been to dunedin before
and that we were there we had food in
our hands so thought [ __ ] whether it's
their house or not the door was
open
um when parked up
had the food
stood up left went down the road and
then um
there's a couple of red and blue lights
um flashing behind us and
um that's basically all the story story
has um still to this day
obviously remorseful and sorry for
the discern that he caused those people
but um
it wasn't much to it to be honest yeah
so did they call the cops on you was
that yeah i think they must have
obviously heard people inside their
house um like i didn't speak to anyone
face to face um
obviously a little bit um
saliva
yeah didn't cause too much harm to
anyone and i just heard this must have
heard someone in the lounge or come
through the front door so they call the
cops and we walk 100 meters down the
road and they're after us
oh that's classic and
obviously the media media had an
absolute feel down there i know you're
not a big fan of the media is that sort
of the reason why um you lost a bit of
trust in the media things stories like
that
a little bit it's probably the other
incidents in the media that i lost trust
with them but look um
i guess that that 24 hours wasn't too
pleasant obviously the the
the cops took me back to the cells um
for questioning
with my mate um
and
sat down and just made sure that both
our stories aligned
i think thankfully they did um because
we didn't have time to chat about
what we were going to say to the police
um
anyway like it wasn't very wasn't very
comfortable
they released us about an hour later
from
from the police station walked back to
the hotel tail between the legs
um
probably at that age
um i i didn't tell anyone i didn't want
to get in trouble and
i was hoping the police didn't tell the
media or i don't know who how it got out
to the media anyway but
um
i thought i'd escaped it um but i got a
call from
tony ward the hurricane's manager at
about 4 30 the following afternoon after
the team had got back from the hotel um
and i was sitting in my lounge
i hadn't even told anyone yet
um and he said mate like what's happened
yeah
we why were you um at the police station
last night so
i just told him well i've told you and
then
darren again the lex manager calling me
i mean joe lock
all blacks media manager calling me and
i had to stand up in front media a day
later and
um
yeah um it wasn't wasn't the best work
but it's all learning
trouble again somehow
yeah talk to me about the other incident
is this the one at the mcg yeah so
um
boxing day test
um
our seven man flat
from secondary at lincoln wanted a
reunion so we thought no better time in
the boxing day test at the mcg against
australia um
had a couple of big big days of viewing
and
big days of grogging um
so then we went around to
might have even been bay third into the
mcg
there's heaps of kiwis down there right
down the bottom uh in the sun
late in the afternoon
in the second session
to be honest i just wanted some
like some fresh air
body and
head and guts was under it um
those went down there everyone just took
their kid off landed in sunblock and
just parked up and watched the cricket
we're probably there for a good hour or
so
all these other kiwis chanting whatnot
i'm just trying to find some peace and
quiet and then one of them recognized me
um under my hat and sunnies
and then there's about i don't know
100 of them just turn around and chanted
um
my name and basically see it off
yeah you know i'm setting me up half a
unit
of
i think it was um what great northern
and they're only um
they're only
2.5 or whatever so
um anyway sitting there in my chair and
reluctantly obviously i didn't even
stand up just sit there in my chair
finish the unit
and then
thought it was happy days they bowled
another ball what not um they'd start
chanting to someone else and then
some little security guard comes down
and texts me on the shoulder and he's
like mate you got to go
i think i've got to go yeah like you
gotta go get another four four beers
like he's like no you got to go
and so all my mates naturally
started arcing up a little bit thinking
like there's a disgrace like what's
happening why is he getting kicked out
um but i knew kind of what could have
been at stake if i'd
kicked up a big fuss and
some people around there might have
recognized me and whatnot so
i just put my put my shoes on
put my shirt on all the other boys put
their kits on as well and we just slowly
walked out in a wee huddle um basically
security dragged us out then stood
outside the mcg getting questioned by
police which was i thought was a
disgrace that's outrageous
so basically um i said like what are we
getting question for and the police just
said look
that's not our decision or it's not our
matter we just have to follow up just a
procedure any incidents where
stadium security kicked people out so
they took my name
and
like i don't know how media got hold of
it again or if those police have gone to
the australian media and whatnot but
so we had a guts full we're fed up with
the way we're treated so we just went
straight back to our accommodation
um basically to have a shower whatnot
and get changed and then go out
into the afternoon or night to find a
local park and watch the rest of cricket
and
phone started going off again
and it was um why don't joe lock all x
media manager glenn and then tony ward
again thinking what's happened what's
going on over there i'm thinking this is
deja vu like not again
no
yeah
and then but the thing that just didn't
sit well with me was
the headlines were
um drunken or disorderly or alcohol
related incident with me at that stadium
and that was tagged to my name um
i wouldn't mind if one of them actually
just called me up and just asked me what
happened get my side out there um
i was about to put it out through my
social media channels what had happened
um
but i thought look the horses bolted
here um
everything's out there i'll just try and
enjoy the next three or four days with
my mates so
we made sure we did that mate that is
absolutely outrageous eh half a vessel
and you're gone that's loose
i was expecting way more yeah i know
it's it's actually
when when people ask about the two
stories there's actually not much
substance to them at all so
um yeah another kiwi dude must have seen
it happening so he actually videoed me
finishing the drink and then got the
whole ordeal and it's that's so
so placid like
we just couldn't believe that
you kicked out of a stadium for doing
that but look i've learned learn that
now you can have you had to change the
way you act out in public now because um
obviously in your uni days you would
have been doing a lot more things than
that but now
you drink half a beer at the mcg and
you're you're out like i think in new
zealand people are pretty good
and
no not really just be yourself and just
don't just don't carry on the one thing
it did start was the whole justice for
geordie campaign which still lives on
people people love that one yeah the
whole justice for jordy thing um it was
actually a bit of a laugh and
i boosted my morale to be honest i was
sitting there and i was in one again
like
down in the dumps and people calling me
names in the media suddenly thinking how
am i going to enjoy these next three or
four days
but yeah those videos that come out
there are awesome
like i said before boost the spirits a
wee bit and
i guess light in the situation right
hundred percent and no one did a better
one than your good mate mitchell he did
one of the great justice for
oh chubby great man
they'll stop there
another big moment in your hurricane's
career was another one sort of off the
field was uh your brother leaving your
brother leaving off to the blues
mate talk to me about that how did how
did that whole process go down with you
to be honest mate like i was never too
worried and never put any pressure on
him um
probably not until the last
week when it got to d-day and
i could tell i could tell it was a
massive decision for him um
understandably
all his connections to the hurricanes
everything he'd done for the club
won a title there um
and i knew that he wanted to move up to
auckland at some stage
of his career and
like he he was open and honest with me
the whole time and it didn't worry me
too much obviously would have loved
having him there and
obviously would have preferred for him
to stay in wellington but
i think the last week
when he was making that decision was
quite funny we played golf
twice i think and
both times um
while i was playing with ricky and
ricky's golf garden he'd just keep
dropping in certain little um
phrases like [ __ ] imagine
imagine turning down this sort of stuff
we're driving around having a few beers
playing golf like how can you leave this
like
who's you who's going to be in your
4-ball up in auckland um just
antagonizing them and
modi's got
a long fuse like you'll never see and
lose it or get frustrated i don't think
i ever have but all you can see is kind
of getting it boiling point a little bit
i just like
these
cowboys and this other golf cart
obviously trying to win a glock game as
well just
absolutely getting at him but
it was all in good spirit and he made
his decision for him and his family so
i'm happy for him and now ricky's gone
up too
yeah i know
it didn't last too long no
but you're you're hanging around you're
you're still signing with the canes for
how many more years have you got you
usually sign one at a time don't you
because yeah
you've got all the you've got all the
pool no way get it
look what i like we've seen before
look covered um trying times around the
world didn't even know what's around the
corner so
you should say i saw this pandemic
coming four years ago
right now look um with my next contract
i'd like to sign a longer one and um
and i was locking in new zealand for for
a lot longer and like i'm enjoying my
time at hurricanes
um
who knows i might try and go away for a
stint somewhere in between um hopefully
i can tie it into a contract somewhere
um
who knows potentially
that minos into japan or hey
see how we go but look i'm signed in new
zealand for another year
um obviously with a goal of winning a
world cup and ideally playing for the
all blacks so i just want to keep yeah
keep moving forward
i like it but you guys are handing
around that suntory contract uh beauty
to d mecca you it must be you next isn't
it
i don't know if there'll be much left by
the time it comes to me
they better have plenty because
your value on that market would be worth
a fortune
ah look jenna well i didn't find out um
they by all accounts they love their
time in japan i think damien's just gone
to quarantine now um
i think he's six days in he's getting
sick of cold bento boxes um and power
outages so i'm pretty sure he's over
oh but you spent some time there in
japan at the last rugby world cup let's
talk about that rugby world cup from
your perspective
yeah it was an interesting one
i didn't play the pool stages first
gaming in south africa was a big game in
yokohama
i think it was
um
got through the pull stages pretty well
and
through the quarters against ireland
and then basically had a roadblock
against um england and they all crashed
in front of our eyes to be honest and
like there's a lot of learnings we got
from that tour that hopefully we can
write a wrong next world cup if lucky
enough to be there healthy and selected
so
um
yeah i think looking back now i can't
really actually remember too much
hopefully i've taken plenty of learnings
but
it's not ideal not ideal crashing out in
the semi you know you got so much
expectation in a black jersey uh we felt
as i would let the
country and ourselves down a wee bit um
so yeah there's
uh something burning inside the a lot of
the boys at the moment and um yeah eyes
france and 23. and what's it like
sitting on a bench you were you're on
the bench in that um semi-final weren't
you what was the feeling like sitting on
that bench were you just
real keen to get on or was that such a
big moment where you stand to think i
don't mind if i don't go on here
i was so keen to get on like yeah
you know me gentle i wanted to be out
there starting or out here as soon as
possible and
i was left on there quite late yeah and
it was just i was hating it like sitting
there the game was tight um things
weren't going our way and i just wanted
to get out there and
i guess try and contribute to the match
um the other thing that was burning in
the back of my mind was i was on the
bench as a utility so i'm thinking
i'm not going on there my left one go my
full back am i going on as a right wing
what if one of the midfielders go down
yeah um
i think i went on there as a left wing
never played there before in my life
um
so yeah i was a little bit taken back by
that but look grateful for that
experience gave me a taste of what
things are like at that level um in
those circumstances so yeah great
learning experience how hard is it for
the week having to cover so many
positions i'd imagine that all blacks
would have a pretty big playbook lots of
different calls if you're covering from
12 to 15 there's a lot of different
roles you have to learn how hard's that
um it's as hard as
you want to make it for yourself um at
their age
i wasn't like i was i prepared well
enough i'd kind of learn my role during
the week
during the clarity sessions do a few
mental reps during the week and then
just get out and train um
i probably didn't i certainly didn't
prepare um as deep as i did then um as i
do now sorry so
i kind of just glossed over all the
little detail within those roles and it
probably didn't or certainly didn't help
um
the way
i'd go into those games like you'd be on
edge a little bit um
and that's just a part of the whole
phase of going through
as a footy player like
now i'm doing that much extra homework
preparing so much deeper
so then i'm now i'm just going out with
a clear head and just able to
um express myself and back my instincts
and
hopefully starting to show in my footy
but throughout those early years yeah
you kind of just prepare
um just scratch the surface and then
obviously trying hard but you know how
it is you kind of gloss over a little
things and
um but now that thing's a little bit
different and
yeah working in my favor of it mate is
it what mate some great advice there
geez you've come up trumps with a few
pieces of wisdom throughout this podcast
i am loving it like i said shame i'm
retired man maybe next year for tazzy
i'll chuck the boots on with all this
jordy barrett wisdom
[Laughter]
but what what are your plans going
forward you mentioned um
all blacks is the goal
um have you thought any further than
that um would you always stay in rugby
union i know you've got
a lot of people compare you to the great
tom travojvic
who i understand you even got to meet
uh at the grand final this year talk to
me about that one actually
yeah it was um
i'm an avid league supporter grew up
loving rugby league following it with my
brothers and
um
yeah i'll sit down most weekends and
almost watch every regular league game
but i coded but um yeah it was awesome
going to that grand final um like we're
sitting there
we've done a we've been on a bus from
the goldie to brisbane
and
well there might be an hour and a half
or two hours from memory
and a few beers on the bus going up
there um
a few beers during the first half and
i didn't know what like obviously a bit
of a fanboy i thought and i'd had a skin
full i was sitting there watching the
game
and tommy turbo was down there talking
to jonathan thurston i'd just done a
halftime show
and
i just sat there and um
i was sitting beside scooter and my
brother and i was like should i go down
there and he was like obviously he had a
skin full as well and he thought yeah
bro just go just go
i went down there
like way to myself oh i went straight
down the stairs
and saw turbo standing there he's taking
photos like selfies with like these kids
and other fans like leaning over the
advertising hoardings
i was walking down there that's when it
sort of hit me it's like lucky you're a
cowboy like he's gonna
think what's this yoga doing anyway
um got to tommy and i was like hey bro
can obviously um have a selfie
and he looked at me like sideways
i don't think he recognized me which was
good um
and then got a photo of tommy um
he chucked out my story obviously and
yeah it was it was a great final um
he obviously saw the saw the story and
reached out to me that night and
i apologized him for pestering him and
not letting him have some peace on it on
a night he probably didn't want to have
to deal with too many people
oh that's so good
i thought you must have had a few to go
down and get that photo
yeah i certainly did
i'm surprised he didn't recognize you
though because um obviously he probably
bases part of his game on yours i'm not
sure leagues probably don't watch too
much from the union um
well maybe he just didn't want to have a
chat to me he probably had a gut when i
want to hit up the tunnel which is fair
enough
you were just slurring
but would you ever give league a go to
be honest every
off season or every time i'm sitting
there watching a rugby league game i
think [ __ ] i'd love to go over there and
play some league like just for a season
um
and who knows i might um
i can see before it crosses my mind a
lot
i'm just i'm not sure what position i'd
play i'd love to just go over there and
just give it a crack um
who knows you'd have to be full back
wouldn't you tommy turbo junior
or even senior potentially
could take him down as the dell em you'd
be that good at it
i i wouldn't be able to tie the shoe
laces
um
like maybe five maybe even five eight
wouldn't mind um kicking the skin a few
times on fourth or fifth tackle few 40
20s or putting up some floater bombs
oh yeah that's why you'd love the tackle
floatable
defending in the front line yeah um
trying to put some shots on and you're
allowed to be a grub in that game so i
love it
yeah mate you'd be bloody good so golf
league and rumor has it well jordan
tells me you might be off to afl is that
what glon said glow on glow and reckons
you and him are off to a training camp
no chance
i'm not running around a circle pitch
all day mind you i actually love the
game afl too yeah um
yeah i've i set there um last year when
i was at the cricket and i think the afl
guys are in their pre-season you saw
them training and whatnot um be good to
go over there and learn learn how to
kick a
ball properly um for a couple weeks yeah
to be fair that's all that will said oh
yeah
all that cricket so you've got the black
clash coming up as well mate you're
you're just gifted at all sports i'll
probably get skittled at that black
clash that's their jabber um preparation
hasn't been great normally i'll try and
have a few games with pr mccreek club um
club back in taranaki but i will try to
get a few games in before then
so we don't multi yeah we don't multi-up
as the top run scorer this year
i don't know it depends if i'm betting
in that power play where you get double
runs
surely surely the guys target you for
that round
look just don't put me in your multi if
i'm bowling
the one up hold last year
oh
so many options for you though mate so
good but even even options are in the 15
man game so you've sort of made your
home at full back now
rumor has it that you were looking to
make a shift into the midfield for the
canes this year
um
are you going to change your plan there
or was that ever even a plan
yeah i'd be lying if i said
i hadn't spent
a few hours in this quarantine hotel i'm
thinking about my transition into 12
um
something i might do at some stage
whether it's this year or next year or
further down the track but
like i was at 12 growing up with most of
my footy um i feel like my skill set
suits there
um who knows
i guess i've got the next month
and a half to figure out um
which avenue i'll go down but look i'm
i'm happy with the way i'm going at 15
but got a serious eye to playing 12 at
some stage so
it's probably not a matter of if it's a
matter of when mate exciting times so
many options geez i'd love to be your
agent he he must live the dream
and what's your plans post footy have
you got much plan
um you mean when i retire yeah and maybe
what 10 years 10 years when you retire
what's
what's the plans if i'm lucky enough to
play for another 10 years
yeah it's been a pretty good career um
look i'm not too sure yet i i love the
farm love getting home to the neckie
with family farmers and brothers there
so who knows um yeah something along
that line would you work on the farm
yeah um
yeah i could easily work on the farm i
love doing farm work um i'm i'd probably
get sick of pulling tits every morning
though um
not a morning person but look
that can change pretty quickly but i
just enjoy it and enjoy that lifestyle
and being in the community and um i love
love all that aspect of farming and what
did you study down at uni we didn't even
mention it it didn't sound like you're
doing a heck of a lot of it but i've got
an unfinished bachelor of commerce
degree
so i got through 12 papers
of commerce and then went up to
wellington
and so that was on hold
the year i got injured i think in 2017
after the hurricane semi-final in joburg
um
i injured my shoulder i had surgery so i
went down to lincoln did two more years
of summer school i mean two more papers
of summer school um
over those months so i chipped away a
little bit more but haven't touched it
for three or four years yeah are you
gonna look to finish it or
don't i ah probably not i would have
liked to but um just with the way footy
is now and
switching on and
i guess it is a part of switching off
too and getting that brain going um yeah
i'd rather do something a little bit
different golf golf fishing
yeah oh yeah you're a good fisherman too
aren't you you and uh we where's where's
hilson
yeah i got a little boat in wellington
last year it's just
[Music]
um oh like a four meter or three and a
half meter tiny um
it takes on a bit of water but it kisses
that gets us out into the harbour
um we've had a few close calls down on
the cook straight um
that's good yeah i think we disappear
behind the swell a few times um backing
ourselves a little bit but
yeah there's been a few hearing
crossings with liam mitchell rickettelli
um and wiz going out
boat's starting to fill up with water
and
chappie is trying to shovel the water
out of the boat
um
we've even tried a couple of times night
fishing in that harbour
going out with a yellow boom and a few
beers and just sitting on the harbour um
catching a little
rap snapper um under the limit
it's hard to catch some that are
actually good to keep
but these things and stuff that go there
go through there but we haven't been
lucky enough to strike yet but it's more
just
the principle there jenna out on the
water
that's uh living the dream
yeah but mate what a journey as always
we have gone to the instagram for some
questions and whenever we get a big dog
on the questions seem to absolutely blow
up and made at the moment there's not
too many bigger dogs in yourself
so we'll race through some of these but
plenty of them were about the mac as one
like i've already mentioned however
young there
um this one came up probably the second
most how do you get your power and your
goal kick
everyone wants to know what's the secret
me included power and the goal kick
to be honest
well for a start just trying to kick the
skin off it that's it goes a long way to
kicking it far but
and the fact that i'm 6'4 just natural
physics probably helps a little bit too
um but look
at the top of my mark i've got this
little thing where i'll lean forward and
go up my toes three times um
and ben blair um x all black spent a lot
of time kind of blues crusaders good
goal kicker
he got that into my game when i was down
at lincoln and it's more just about
trying to feel light on your feet and
lights on your toes
you stand at the top of your mark and
you're on your heels you don't really
feel that good about yourself so
it's more about just being feeling light
on your feet a couple of forward presses
going up on your front toes
and that just makes you feel nice and
like you've got a bit of rhythm
i guess to step back and we'll run up
there just to try and generate a little
bit of flow
and then just like
as you probably see just a bit of
a gentle tilt and some forward momentum
and i think the biggest thing to
kicking far
punting or off off a tee is landing on
your same kicking leg
so
obviously you've got your plant for your
kicking leg when your kicking leg comes
through actually landing on that same
leg
um it just transfers power
well for me
and i've found anyway so that'll be my
biggest thing land on the same kicking
leg mate that is some good stuff and
even you even me you even kick
pretty much
you the same as when you're right in
front like maybe 10 meters out compared
to when you're 60 meters out don't you
just you just smack it no matter where
you are is there a reason behind that or
because not not everyone does that oh no
i think like
just so i can get consistent ball fly
even if i'm right in front or 10 meters
metres the left of the stacks
is
a penalty well i have my i've got a long
routine and a short routine
um in the short routine it's basically a
two or three step
um
and that's i like to bring that in so i
don't have to take it all the way back
to the 22 there's just more margin for
error but it's just so people
don't charge my long
long routine
but um
yeah like i guess even if i'm in front
on the 22 kicking of penalty i'll still
try and kick it hard and with the same
amount of power well not hard just a
good strike with plenty of rhythm
just so there's no difference
um and ball flight like
you see some guys chipper around there
and miss every now and then so it just
takes all that yeah out of it mate i
like it and the next question around
that was what's the longest kick you've
ever landed
obviously
at training some windy days you must
have landed one from for
a decent length
longest kick ever landed to be honest
i've never actually gone back past
i've kicked one from 64 in wellington
before and that was documented on world
rugby um
but i've never i've never actually gone
back past 60 at training um yeah that's
kind of my marker if i go back past the
six pass or to 60 60 meters
and clear it across barbed wire three or
four meters or then i just take that as
being over like i'm not going to go back
to 65 and try hit the crossbar i'll
probably lose my hamstring
but i've never been back to south africa
um for a few years now but
um
i can't wait to get back onto the high
valves wow yeah altitude there
and here trying this one i might try a
line one up from 65 maybe a little bit
further
before me
that would be good stuff and what do you
make of that um kicking comp your head
with elliott daley was did you know how
far he had been able to kick it or what
was the what was the process there are
you just poking the beer jimmy
[Laughter]
now world record world rugby told me
that it's um we're going to kick on the
same day and same conditions
and he won't know um what i've kept and
then i see the footage come out and you
know how far i've kicked it
um and i can see i can hear in the
camera and on whatever they're recording
on there's a howling gail
and he's picked on some club ground so
you wake up your own mind
got it so let's let's put it straight
have you got a longer kick than elliott
daley
for the record look um
they're
going off that footage in world rugby
statistics i don't
but
there's only one way to sort it and
that's
get us together at one ground and have a
kick off
or do it in a game that's it oh i look
forward to that maybe they should do
they should do something like that have
some races everyone wants to know who
the fastest guys all the time let's get
them all on the field and give them a
race let's see who the longest kicker is
oh what a day that would be
yeah
okay next question who would win in a
scrap out of the brothers this would be
this would be a bloody good fight
um a scrap out of the brothers what sort
of scrap
um
what do you reckon uh
just a backyard scrap oh yeah no weapons
no weapons
if it's nowhere if there's no weapons in
the backyard scrap well then that just
completely rules blake and i out um
lake's been known to throw cricket bats
before
um
weapons actually
one day i remember um
blake and i had the upper hand on body
and cricket one day we might have
smacked him off or
knocked him over anyway
not sure if you if these those 10 shot
fireworks are still around oh yeah yeah
but basically we've got bodhi out scott
was there too i remember and would send
him packing
saying that you know that chant no no no
no
he's gone into his room or somewhere
down the shed and got those 10 shot
fireworks and he comes sprinting around
the side of the house
with these fireworks and just starts um
pointing them straight at us boys
and i remember getting hit in the head
with one of these 10 shot fireworks and
singing my hair so
i think he won that fight but i think in
terms of a
wrestle or a glove up probably be kane
or scott no doubt which one kane wasn't
mongrel kane was kane was a tough bugger
yeah
i genuinely would bat cane yeah yeah
fair enough more like that
big cattle so would go right too
okay next one when are you going to make
your coastal debut
everyone's hanging out for this hey i'd
love to make my coastal day though um
i'm hanging out i've i've tried to put
it in my
one-year contracts that you were talking
about before to have a postal game um
not enough money in the bank
coastal not paying you now all for love
jimmy you know that beauty's played for
the may has scott
yeah quite a full season scott hasn't so
i i think he wants to big time as well
but
yeah love the coast try to get back
there and watch as much as i can blake's
played over a hundred games for them now
so um
yeah i'd hate to see what blake puts me
through um in one of their court
sessions or their initiation so probably
best not play for them at all
and where's kana he he completely can't
play at all can he
no he can't play at all i don't know
he's probably cooper um he's happy as
he's got a young family um and wife down
he's on the farm
back in the neck he was coaching coastal
for a couple years um but he just he
just bought his own um dairy farm
on the coast living the dream oh loves
it mate he'll be loving that for sure
okay the next one has come from the
great [ __ ] dane coles he sent in three
questions
first question is why is he so grumpy
i don't know why he's on my case now in
grumpy i just had him up every single
morning with an abs cam
saying put us like telling him to put a
smile on his face like he walks
downstairs
like he's gonna kill someone every day
and i'm like what's up dane and he just
like grabs me or like tries to punch me
in the ribs
and he's like
he's like mate it's this week
i'm like yeah but relax you can smile
and like have a chat with me down he's
like nah [ __ ] off
oh that knuckle guy geez i love him our
next one was you are the world's biggest
grub just a statement
a statement from dane not a question
okay
i feel like he
he must have seen that through to you in
his glass house jabber
what do you reckon are you a grub you
used to love the um collar grab you were
very good at the collar crab too until
quentin strange got you one week
you're almost so good at the color grab
that
maddie proctor and a few boys and coals
in the canes we actually started
training the collar grab we grabbed
those stretch bands in the gym and hold
them up and
actually train collar grabbing for the
weekend um
it probably didn't
go too well for the team ended up
getting penalized for
um retaliation
and a high penalty count for a few years
because boys were so highly strung
i had four older brothers growing up
jabber and um i was a ticking time bomb
for for the most part um i just
antagonised me and it didn't take too
much to get a bite so um
i guess that's
is a bit of that further aside me
you're not too bad on the field though
are you i look off i'd like to think
i've grown out of that phase a wee bit
jabber and
control
that sort of niggle um and use it in the
right form but
it's still a little bit there somewhere
well if anyone can teach you how to use
your niggle that's dang coles oh that's
right you learn from the best
oh man he still loves it eh okay and the
last one he sent in is why do you want
to fight ben may at captain's run
oh i think he's referring to
a time in
sydney waratahs first game of the season
and
like i said before i was pretty blase of
my preparation when i was younger then
hang on it might have been the game that
um
you'd pop your shoulder together oh
geez carmichael hunt
nightmares when you put your head in the
slope and try to tap your thumb off your
hand
i turned up to kevin's run didn't have
the right socks on and they knew i had a
short fuse and i'll just buy to anything
obviously very competitive
and i think they're having a red hot
crack at me so i'll just bite back and
it got to a point where during captain's
run he'd kept coming over and standing
beside me enough and talking to me and
like trying to pull up my ankle socks
that i was wearing that i was
sus cleansed wanted to
drop him but
i knew bama obviously good may and i
could just never do that but geez i was
that boiling point
that would have been some scrap it tells
you just being back around like poking
and prodding and laughing and like
oh i actually thought more about turning
around and chinning him
oh because he's good at that though just
poking the beer from a distance
okay last question for the don
one piece of advice geordie barrett has
for our listeners and i know you've
scattered some great insight throughout
this podcast i'm looking forward to your
best one
look i've got a quite a few pieces of
advice chad but look i think um for the
young listeners
like the kids and people at high school
like
i guess just thinking about myself the
the best
the thing that set me up most for my
career and where i am now is what i did
when i was at primary school and at high
school like
i'd spend hours and hours just on bare
feet kicking a ball at primary school
over the post
playing footy
never inside
um at school
bell would finish should go back to the
hostel chuck my boots on if we didn't
have footy training and i'd just go down
and just kick goals
until dinner
and it was a stable cricket um at home
on the lawn just bowling bowling bowl
and bat with my brothers so
i guess i end
like i was fit at that age like i i did
a lot of long distance cross-country
running and mom always said to me look
yes
my parents are never really pushy around
um things within our footy
um with how well we played or what we're
doing they never actually give any
advice the only thing that mum ever
pushed us boys into was getting fit
um
and so we'd have
we'd be training long distance all the
time and she only ever said she made us
do it because we just enjoy it more um
and once we're through the other side
we found we did enjoy it we're better at
it better at sport we enjoyed it because
of fit and i guess thankful for i guess
doing a lot of work as a young kid um
i feel like it's too late to start
training hard when you're 18 19 or in
academies or trying to make up later but
the best work you do is when you're
a shin kicker running around um with a
footy boring hand
mate
oh that is so good get fit that is great
advice from
robin
yeah yeah robin robin barrett absolute
legend
learn from the best
oh my absolute pleasure having you on
the podcast uh it's been a long time
coming this one i've been i've been
waiting for years to get you on and uh
yeah like i said at the start i'm stoked
to have you on obviously i love my time
playing with you at the keynes
you're an absolute lad champion bloke so
it's been awesome having you on the
podcast
thanks very much for having me jabba
it's been a pleasure
and last piece of advice enjoy stop and
smell the roses along the way enjoy it
that's uh anymore mate you've got so
much advice one more
just cut me off jabber cut me off
that's like foghorn